hi it's Matthew Martin a details and i'm
here at the prada show it was all about
simplicity the first look was literally
a sweater over a shirt with a pair of
cropped pants and a clunky shoe it was
such a refreshing way to open his show
especially football winter there wasn't
a lot of stuff it was just like a very
basic way of dressing that was super
chic and clean also you know is about a
simple suit it was about a great top
coat you know instead of being a classic
it really fitted to the body code they
had these almost like a boxy or
proportion which would give it a little
bit more of a modern feel even though it
was an update of aquatic piece most of
the shirts had a ruffle down the front
placket which gave it a really playful
feel especially for you know in everyday
shirt there was a sort of leather bomber
/ blazer combination shoes really cool
colors and the leathers like a couple of
red or the brown one you know there was
like a blue I love the fact that in a
heavy winter season when you think it's
going to be tons of layering and lots of
heavy fabrics it was really really
beautiful and it was very light very
like it was really a breath of fresh air
for more shows from Milan please go to
details calm and you can follow me on
instagram and twitter at details map